uh you recently wrote a post uh about uh
the potential death of ethereum um
explain a little bit of what the thought
process there is and kind of what you
think the probabilities are sure so i'm
a trader by nature right so i'm a chart
analyst i'm i do price study every day
and when i'm looking at the ethereum
versus bitcoin chart not the ethereum
versus the dollar chart but specifically
ethereum versus bitcoin i'm seeing a
breakdown in the chart so the price is
going lower we're below 0.06 today um
and that is off of the uh a high of you
know spot one five you know a couple
years ago so we've had lower highs made
over the course of now several years in
ethereum and it's showing a pattern that
is
mirroring the death of other altcoins
that we saw
take a boom in the last cycle and so
it's it's really a price study only
opinion here and i'll be quick to change
the opinion if the price reverses right
now the price of ethereum versus bitcoin
looks very suspect it is breaking down
it is making new lows
and it has made
lower highs over the course now four
years when you think about uh that type
of analysis i think it's important to
caveat you're just looking at a price
chart this is an only price and listen
it is only a price analysis that i'm
doing with ethereum now
you could say the same thing about
bitcoin when i got into bitcoin it was
because the price analysis told me this
is an exponential trend that is
uh is
live and right in front of us and so i
got involved then i started to
learn more and more about bitcoin and
then i finally decided to purchase
bitcoin once once i believed that i had
married
the long thesis on the chart with the
long thesis of the fundamentals i did
that and then i purchased it so
when looking at ethereum i'm not
factoring in the fundamentals of the
network
or their potential switch away from
proof of work but i do believe that the
price represents all the information
that is available in the market and so
maybe it is that the traders that are
viewing the future of ethereum are
viewing it unfavorable unfavorably and
that's why the price is declining but i
lead with price i always have
and um it it hasn't led me wrong because
when you think that price is truth if
the price declines or reverses in a way
that goes against what you thought you
have to alter your perspective you can't
just be sitting on your positions
forever and so like for example if
bitcoin were to go
materially below 19500
we're going to have to take a look at
this asset what has hap why is it broken
down below the last all-time high of
2017 five years later with all this
growth the growth of the network
until then
the long thesis is sound in bitcoin but
yeah in the below 20 000 we're gonna
have to take a look at it